Gordon s wood author of the American
Revolution the history when did you
first get interested in history
that's a good question probably in
college I was a history major I went to
Tufts and somehow or other I just always
had a had a yearning to to study
although I wasn't planning on being
historian I was originally gonna go into
the Foreign Service can you remember
when you first got interested in history
say in high school or even grade school
no because it was taught so coolly in
high school I can't imagine why I would
have been interested in it from the from
the high school teacher he used to have
us read from mozzie the textbook that
was how we did history each each would
read a paragraph he'd go up and down the
row and I would plan ahead when I would
be reading and then I'd go ahead and
read on my own and keep my finger on the
spot which I would have to read but so
it was not because of the teaching it
was just something I I was interested in
despite the very bad high school teacher
we had where did you grow up I grew up
in New England Greater Boston lived in
Worcester for a while but graduated from
Waltham high school which is little
little town right outside of Boston and
do you remember your first character in
history that you got interested in
that's a good question
probably in the in graduate school I
became fascinated with James Madison it
was that late I didn't have any hero
earlier I don't think of why I can't
think of one at least
but in graduate school I became
fascinated with Madison why Madison
because of his intellectual abilities
I've got less enthralled by him as time
is going on but at the time back in the
1966 tease I thought he was a most
remarkable politician in American
history because he was a thinker as well
as a political figure so why have you
become lessons well because I think he I
think he's actually much more
ideological than I had thought and not
quite as wide-ranging and as
intellectually creative as I had
originally thought but he's still quite
a remarkable man what's his ideology
well he's totally caught up in a MIDI
ology of what you might call Republican
his notion of an alternative to war
which is quite appropriate today that is
to say commercial sanctions the embargo
which is usually identified with
Jefferson but it's really Madison's
embargo that that that he promotes that
is using commercial retaliation as an
alternative to using troops which we
would call economic sanctions he's very
much a proponent of that and very much
caught up in it which led to his
peculiar behavior during the War of 1812
as president now Waltham Massachusetts
is in the suburbs of Boston and a lot of
the characters in this small book you
have here I know you've written a lot
bigger books on the American Revolution
I come from that area
let's try one Samuel Adams Samuel Adams
real revolutionary probably the first
one of the first to aim for independence
I think he probably believed in
independence as early as 1768 so he's a
he's a kind of fanatic a rabble rouser
and but a very skillful politician as
well who believed more devoutly than
some of the other revolutionaries in
Republican severity ascetic they had to
fit him out with clothes to send him to
Philadelphia because he didn't pay much
attention to how he dressed although he
was a Harvard graduate and a gentleman
nonetheless very interesting character
how did he relate to John Adams they
were distant cousins John Adams was
equally fanatical if you will as a
revolutionary but a little more skilled
I think as an attorney and as a speaker
and probably much more intellectual than
his cousin Samuel Adams have you done
the freedom trail around Boston some of
it but because I was a Bostonian I took
those things for granted it took me it's
when visitors come to Boston they want
to go to the they want to go to the
Freedom Trail I would I would end up
going often happens when you live in a
lot of tourist attractions but you know
one of the things you see in Boston
right away is the John Hancock building
yeah the new one now when you look at
that what do you think oh who was John
Hancock
well John Hancock was probably the most
successful Massachusetts politician in
the last quarter of the 18th century in
in the in in the state's history he had
lots of money he inherited a fortune
from his from his uncle who was really
his his he was an adopted he uncle
treated him as a son and he inherited
the fortune he went through it because
he was not interested in mercantile
business but interested in political
career and he did that by patronizing
people he bought he he engaged in
patronage that that made him a very
powerful politician he built ships he
didn't need he distributed money he held
parties on the Boston Common he had
about I think John Adams said 2,000
people directly dependent upon him so he
he was a an eighteenth-century
politician of great skill John Hancock
had 2,000 people dependent all right
because I think you said John Adams I
meant John Adams said that go to this
book this is a small version of what you
do why the small book
well editor at at Random House asked me
if I would be willing to write a book on
the American Revolution forty thousand
words it seemed like a great challenge
that I think was the challenge to press
all the information we have about the
Revolution or the Revolutionary era
which runs roughly 1760 to 1790 into one
hundred and sixty-six pages that was a
challenge and to try to make account for
every event and still get it within that
that small compass is it was it was an
interesting challenge and and since I
had been working on the revolution for
what 40 years I said well I can do this
easily it was a little more difficult
than I I had anticipated
is this your specialty oh yes I've spent
my whole career really on the revolution
although I teach much more broadly early
American history from from the beginning
1607 you might say or the late 16th
century up
through era of Jackson I've concentrated
my writing career on the on the era of
the American Revolution you grew up in
well fam you then went to Tufts why that
University what's that about I went to
Tufts because I had a Latin teacher who
was a graduate of Jackson which is the
women's college at Tufts and she she was
a great influence on me my parents are
not college graduates we're not college
graduates and so I was a little
uncertain about what I should do and she
said you must go to Tufts and it was a
local school I was a commuter and that's
that's the long and short of it what
happened to you there I was a history
concentrator I I had a good good time
there and and loved history what part I
actually was in modern European history
mostly non American history although I
had a good American history teacher a
man named Bartlett rule Bartlett but I
was in modern European history and when
I applied to graduate school I was not
certain I was going to work in American
history or modern European history that
is 18th 19th 20th century American
modern European history where'd you get
your graduate degree I went to Harvard I
was in the military for a couple of
years and applied from overseas that was
in Japan stationed in Japan in the Air
Force and applied to graduate school
from there and was accepted at Harvard
with a with a fellowship and so I went
what's the dissertation it was the book
that resulted in the creation of the
American Republic which is a 1776 1787 a
study of political theory and
constitution making in that decades time
it's it was I think the most important
period in American history and the most
importantly one of the great periods of
constitutionalism in Western history and
that was the the dissertation that that
resulted in that book how many books
have you written well I've written
that's the third if you
books articles I have lots of articles
but only three books and edited a couple
of things as well now a couple years ago
I remember Newt Gingrich when he was
speaker used your name about every 15
minutes along with others he said go out
and read the founding of America by
Gordon wood what was the actual title of
the book the radicalism of the American
Revolution which he he liked because it
had a kind of took Billy in touch to it
I guess maybe suggesting American
exceptionalism that he liked and that's
true in in in the fall or the spring it
was the spring of 1994 before he became
Speaker before the big election he was
actually my Minority Whip he invited me
to dinner at the house dining hall and I
got to know him from just that one
conversation I knew nothing of him and I
haven't seen him since but he liked the
book which was of course a kind of kiss
of death for me among a lot of academics
who are not right-wing Republicans and
therefore Debbie to be praised by
Gingrich was not was not necessarily a
good thing from among my peers what did
they say well I felt that Gingrich likes
it it can't be a good book so I got a
little flack from that what did you say
to him well I said well I can't I can't
determine who what readers are gonna
make up my book I I tried to write a
book that radicalism book was a book
that I intentionally tried to reach both
my peers that his fellow scholars appeal
to them saying something new to them at
the same time reach out to a more
general audience an educated audience
that work that was not made up of
experts that's a very difficult thing to
do and yet I think most of us who are
professional scholars as we teach
history I have been unable to reach a
general audience and that's the mental
because history is meaningless if it
doesn't reach out to too large numbers
of people and there's a good deal of I
think jealousy and in the academic world
of people like David McCullough who have
a large readership and it's our own
fault we're writing for one another and
become very narrow and very specific
there's a place for that too but at the
same time I think we have an obligation
to to reach a large readership as well
go back to your comment about your peers
not liking the fact that Newt Gingrich
was heralding your book there are
conservatives watching this program
they're saying yeah that's what's wrong
with academia they're not the slightest
bit interested in the other side well
there is of course and it has been over
the last well maybe thirty years a good
deal of criticism of of ourselves
there's self-criticism I don't think
that that that's wrong I think any
democracy any healthy democracy has to
have a a certain amount of
self-criticism and that often takes the
form for historians of writing
critically about the past I think that
can be excesses in that and I think
people who say that the American
Revolution was a failure I'm making a
mistake but nonetheless one understands
that that self-criticism is a healthy
thing and I have no I have no gripe with
that and it goes on all the time and I
think that's good I think it goes too
far if you begin to see your past as
it's totally full of false and and they
not see any any good at all as I try to
say in the introduction to this book I
don't think our history should be seen
as a moral tale either good or bad I
think historians should try to
understand where we came from as
honestly as as we can without trying to
say this was a great celebration or that
this was a disaster I don't think either
of those extremes are true I don't want
to put words in your mouth are you
saying that a lot of academics think
that the Revolution was bad well I
that's too strong I think there are a
lot of academics who have emphasized
over the last thirty years that we
didn't do enough we didn't for example
free slaves we didn't changed a lot of
women and because those are current
issues there is always a tendency in
history to go back and to look at the
past through the lenses of the present
and lament the fact that slavery was not
abolished and that the lot of women did
not changed substantially and that the
lot of Indians was was was worsened by
the revolution that those are those
facts are true but I think it's an Akron
is tick to apply 21st century standards
to an 18th century world would they
rather that we stayed as a country under
the the monarch of Great Britain I don't
think anyone goes that far because that
would really undermine the whole history
of the country nonetheless there is of
course the British were much more
British Imperial officials are much more
concerned with the Native Americans with
the plight of the plight of the Indians
than were the the colonists so from that
perspective the British Empire looks
rather benign but from other
perspectives I don't think there are
very many American historians who think
that the break from Britain was it was a
mistake that that actually was a feeling
of some I think historians at the end of
the 20th at the end of the nineteenth
century who were thoroughly Anglo files
and felt that the english-speaking world
should be brought together kind of the
era that lay behind Wilson's Anglo
Anglophilia at that at the time of World
War one so no I don't think there's
anybody riding today who thinks that
this was a terrible mistake I do think
that there were there are lots of
historians who feel that we didn't do
enough for these oppressed oppressed
people particularly black slaves and and
and women I mean I my answer to that is
of course that the the revolution did
really substantially change the climate
in which slavery had existed for
thousands of years slavery had existed
in the Western world without substantial
criticism and the revolution marked a
major turning point it suddenly put
slavery on the defensive I think that's
the point that needs to be emphasized
not that Jefferson didn't free of slaves
but that as a man raised as a slave
holder you know a world that was
dominated by slavery he criticized it
that's what's new that that's the point
that I think needs to be made we had
that come from why why did this
generation suddenly become critics of
slavery and put it on the defensive that
I think is an important point how many
years have you taught at Brown I've been
there since 1969 so the what that's what
the 32 years is what did you do in
between Harvard and Brown I went to a I
had a fellowship at the Institute of
really American history which is
sponsored at Williamsburg which is
sponsored by the college there College
of William and Mary and Colonial
Williamsburg
I had a fellowship for two years then
went to Misha then went to Harvard for
assistant professorship for one year
then went to Michigan at the University
of Michigan in Ann Arbor for two years
and then had the offer from Brown and
since I was in New England or that
seemed to be the place to go and I've
been happy there this Providence
Providence Road how big a college is it
universe it's about 5500 students
undergraduates and about 1,200 graduate
students and now a medical school that's
really the whole of brown and you teach
what now I teach three courses actually
elektra courses one on colonial history
one on the Revolution and one on the
early republic so I rotate these courses
and I teach seminars and small classes
for undergraduates and when the young
student shows up in your class what is
their whole attitude about American
history the revolution well they know
something in many cases because they'd
had good training in high school and
other times they know very little I
think there's a generally speaking not a
great great deal of emphasis placed on
early American history that is history
up to the Civil War in high schools now
that's being taught in many states in
the 8th grade and when they get to high
school they start with the Civil War so
you have a kind of eighth grade
knowledge in many cases among some of
these freshmen which is lamentable
because somehow the implication is that
well history back then isn't as
important as the more recent history
when in fact I think the contrary is
true that is the revolution is the
central event of American history varnon
there's just no more important event and
I mean the Civil War is important
because it saved the Union but but the
but the Revolution created the United
States legally and and and then infused
into our our culture almost everything
we believe liberty equality
constitutionalism all of this comes out
of the Revolution so you can't
understand what it is to be an American
I think unless you get back to the
revolution
so it's lamentable that that youngsters
in high school are not getting early
American history from from in high
school they're they're supposed to be
disposed of that in the 8th grade and in
11th grade they they they work on modern
American history where all the action is
I guess when you first meet with in that
first but 50 minutes how long are your
classes actually I have a teacher on
Tuesday Thursday so I have an hour and
20 minutes to work but so I have a
little bit more flexibility what are the
first things you tell them about the
American Revolution I tell them that
it's the most important event in in for
the reasons I've just suggested in in
American history and that I hope they'll
come away knowing what this country of
ours is about what we why we believe the
things we believe and I end by by
contrasting us with with the Soviet the
former Soviet Union because I think both
both countries had have or we have still
a Universalist ideology with with
Universalist aspirations and that was my
kind of account for the Cold War in in
the last lecture fix to bring it all up
to the present and now we have a
situation of course where we the only
major world power and it's a it's a very
very different situation now what year
would you say the revolution really
started oh well I think most most
historians would say 1763 with the Peace
of Paris creates problems for the
British Empire that forces them to
take steps to reform the Empire which
are the the which is the trigger these
efforts to reform become the trigger for
the revolution which goes beyond an
imperial revolute I mean a and rupee
really break down it's not our
revolution not simply a colonial
rebellion it starts that way but by 1776
it has really become a world historical
event with with larger implications so
that the the I think 1763 is probably
the the date that one would pick as the
starting point you have any idea how
many people there are in the world in
1763 in the world no I don't right off
the top my head but certainly in the in
the stilly I think probably less than a
billion less than a billion people I
would think who knows how many don't
know there in the end
yeah about in 1760 probably almost 2
million 2 million by 1770 so it's still
relatively small compared to the what 8
9 10 million of of England we're about a
fifth of that but we're growing much
faster than than Britain itself so there
is this prospect as Benjamin Franklin
saw it that sooner or later we're going
to pass them the trajectory of the to
the demographic trajectory of the two
parts of the em of the of the Imperial
Empire is the Americans are going to out
strip the British and and sooner or
later he felt the capital would have to
be moved to America was there any place
in the world then it's not that the
population elected their sovereign know
that that's what well they're there were
elections in some parts of the
Netherlands and Switzerland and so on
but no no election of leaders was simply
not except for the British House of
Commons that was the one place where you
had representative government not
representative by our standards because
there's so much corruption and and it
was really only one out of six adults
could vote in in Britain so I
well because of property qualifications
whereas in America in the colonies
because property was so widespread
probably two out of three at out white
males could vote so already we had a
large proportionally speaking a much
larger electorate than any other place
in the world there's simply nothing like
what's going on in colonial America and
then of course after the Revolution
nothing like the kind of electoral
politics that we had simply not matched
anywhere as far as I know in in the
world when did King George the third
become the monarch in Great Britain 1760
he his his father had died so he
inherits the throne from his grandfather
george ii so he's a relatively young man
i think about 20 rather immature but
full of all kinds of visions of what the
empire could be and and naive i guess
we'd have to say as a monic he wanted to
rule in his own right his grandfather
and great-grandfather had been german
born and and really didn't know england
he's the first english Hanoverian that
is coming from the house of hanover
whose english li english trained english
born and thoroughly anglicized with lots
of ambition to be a real king what was
his relationship to the House of Commons
well he is unfortunately the the modern
British party government with with with
the crown being kind of figurehead and
and and really dictated to by by a
majority leader of the House of Commons
hadn't yet evolved that would take
another half century at the same time
George didn't quite understand the
convention that that his ministers
really had to get the the agreement of
Parliament so he appointed whoever he
whomever he wanted as ministers there
his ministers after all His Majesty's
ministers and he ran into a lot of
trouble because these ministers didn't
have the support of at least at first of
the House of Commons so he kept one
ministry after another would would fall
he went through several ministries in
the 1760s until he got to the Lord
who did command a majority in House of
Commons and it was one of these things
where he simply couldn't grasp who could
blame him he couldn't grasp the future
that he had to somehow win the we have
the support of the House of Commons to
support his ministers he simply hadn't
fully understood the future and
historians who have criticized him for
this of course have missed the point he
he had every right to a point whomever
he wanted and of course that's still
true today and technically speaking Tony
Blair is Her Majesty's minister but he
she just appoints the person who has the
majority support in the House of Commons
she doesn't have presumably any choice
in the matter
at least not politically
constitutionally she can appoint
whomever she wanted but it would be a
constitutional crisis if she did how big
was the British Empire in 1760 oh it was
a huge Empire and the richest Empire
since the fall of Rome it encompassed
from the Mississippi to was after 63 at
least 1763 from the Mississippi to to
India and it's an extraordinary
phenomenon it's the greatest phenomena
of the 18th century the growth of this
little island on the northwest of the
European continent becoming a major
world power and people were stunned and
surprised by this how could this little
island do what it done and and it was
the empire that that everyone attributed
to Britain's success so they thought the
loss everyone thought the loss of the
Empire or the North American part of it
at least would would diminish England of
course it didn't happen that way Britain
went on to have its greatest days in the
19th century but everyone predicted that
that would be the end of Britain when
they lose the North American colonies
which is why they stuck so long eight
years in this long struggle to hold on
to their colonies you almost you
answered my question the Revolutionary
War was 8 years long right how many
people from the colonies soon to be
Americans fought on the anti British
side well that's a hard question
the answer I think we may have had as
many as a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand people participating at one
time or another which is a huge
proportion of the population running two
to three million people it certainly was
the largest death total I think about
twenty five thousand men were killed
which was a high highest proportion of
of any of any war except of course for
the Civil War in our history of deaths
so a lot of people were touched by the
war it was eight years long the longest
war in our history until Vietnam so it I
think Americans came out of that most
families had been touched in one way or
another by the war and and it was the
great cause that that gave them a sense
of unity I think that that helped to
make the United States meaningful as a
as a single nation for people that eight
years of experience you say the
declaration independence is thirteen
hundred words roughly yeah and there's a
lot of talk about King George the third
in there most of it is about George the
third how he did this and he did that
and so they mean that personally do they
hate him well I think there was at this
point a good deal of resentment but the
reason they focused on the king is
because that's the only tile EFT in
their understanding of the Empire they
had been forced to to cut loose from
Parliament earlier because the English
said you either under Parliament's
Authority or you not under it and given
that choice I said well we're not under
it and they had worked out by 1774 a
notion that the Empire was was was a
kind of modern Commonwealth they were
tied only to the king so the king was
the last tie and that tie had to be
broken and I think there is resentment
of the king at this point because he had
declared them outlaws he had he had he
or his ministers had made these
decisions these crown decisions to cut
American trade to to regard them as
being beyond the pale of of law and so I
think there is a certain amount of
personal resentment and Thomas Paine of
course writing in January of 1776 was
the first major cry for for independence
and that I think focused people's
attention because
he referred to George the third as the
Royal brute and for God's sakes let's
break from this this royal brute I mean
that's really seditious talk and and
somehow it was left to him to make it
the first statement even though he's a
recent immigrant when did the press
become free in the United States
well I suppose to truly say it was free
was probably not until the 19th century
certainly there were no there was no
possibility of a Tory or a loyalist
press once the Whigs were in control so
but you had a good deal of what we might
call relatively speaking for the 18th
century Free Press in the in the 18th
century colonies and the press was very
important during the revolution but a
truly modern free press is a much later
development as we would understand it in
may in some cases not until the 1960s
with the New York Times Sullivan
decision do you get the kind of freedom
that we that we now take for granted in
in the press do you have people in the
Revolutionary period did you think this
wouldn't have happened if they hadn't
been there oh I think Washington is is
the crucial figure he's unbelievably I
mean it just people have called him the
indispensable figure and and he is as
close to that I normally don't believe
that any individual is indispensable but
in this case Washington as a leader took
seriously these responsibilities of a
virtue of maintaining himself as
disinterested above interests and he he
bought into if you will the etiology of
of the revolution and was sincere about
it he could have become King he could
have been a dictator and he he refused
all of these blandishments all of these
temptations that have of course every
military leader that we can think of
from going back to Caesar through
cromwell through Marlborough and then of
course later
Napoleon always expected political
rewards commensurate with their military
achievements not Washington he had to be
product into coming to the
Constitutional Convention and then to be
President he didn't want to be President
he was reluctant always reluctant to
assume civil power and that reluctance
gave him this power that reluctance to
take power made him trusted and and he's
an extraordinary man and we we just we
were just lucky 1787 was the
Constitutional Convention when was the
first Continental Congress 1774 is the
First Continental Congress the first
meeting of the you got a Stamp Act
Congress earlier in 1765 but the
Continental the First Continental
Congress meets in in 1774 and where did
it meet it met in Philadelphia and when
it did meet there what what was the
status of the colonies at that point
well they're still colonies and we were
still under the king and there was still
a good deal of respect for the king and
there was still lots of people who were
loyal how big I mean what widgets
colonies were the biggest oh the juniors
by far the biggest colony and we forget
that now I think we have to understand
why first four of the first five
presidents were Virginians is because
Virginia really was the United States it
made up a fifth of the population of the
country and and just took it for granted
that it was the leader once Virginia
although Massachusetts was certainly I
think the leader in in the radical
movement and that's where that the
revolution really begins there but for
jigna without Virginia's support the
revolution would never have been brought
off because it it as I say a fifth of
the population of the country is in the
state of Virginia and and once the
Virginians came on board and they were
certainly they rivaled Massachusetts in
their in their leadership then then the
country was was destined to to break
from Britain what was the motive of
people Patrick Henry you mentioned I
think first in your book write 29 years
old or something like that in those
early years yeah it's hard to know about
each of these individual the motivations
of each of these individual leaders
because you reduce it to their their
various ambitions they are an ambitious
group these
revolutionary leaders but Henry makes
his name in the so called Parsons cause
in the 1750s which doesn't seem to have
much to do with the revolution although
looking back you can see it as an
anticipation because Henry really does
attack the established church and
imperial power in general and make some
derogatory comments about about Imperial
leadership so looking back you see it as
a premonition of the revolution I'm sure
nobody at the time in 1758
saw this as as revolutionary but it is a
symptom of the kind of willingness of
young leaders to take on the
establishment if you will so in those
days in the 1758 and all through that
period how many people in this country
were members of the Anglican Church well
I think that about 40% of the population
was tied to established churches whether
Anglican or in New England of course the
established churches were congregational
the old Puritan churches so you still
had a good proportion of the population
tied to European type establishments
that is what tax-supported
state supported churches that all
changes in it of course in the course of
the revolution by 1790 and thirty years
time you have a complete breakdown of
this about 25% of the population remains
tied to established churches not the
Anglicans there they've been there that
the church the Church of England is the
one most hurt by the revolution but the
the you have the rise of new churches in
in the period the Baptist's were
relatively insignificant 1760 R have
emerged by 1790 as the largest group the
Methodists are coming on strong there
were no Methodists in America in the
1760s by 1790 their second largest
Church and and within a few within a
decade or two they become the largest
denomination in America so you have a
really major shift religiously as a
result of the Revolution essentially an
ending of the crust of establishment and
the opening up of of popular religious
religious feelings
evangelical feelings that transforms the
religious landscape of America another
aspect to this radical revolution by the
way you live in a state that has yeah
that does not go along through all those
years well that's right were they at the
First Continental Congress yes they did
go to the they they simply did not
participate in the in the Constitutional
Convention they had been certainly very
radical they were ready to break in fact
they actually Rhode Island the see
they're there their revolution is
proceeding the the 1776 they may 1776
they they changed their Charter and
become a become a republic so they they
actually think of themselves as being
ahead of the rest of the country but but
in 1787 they want no part of this
consolidation this effort to strengthen
the Union because they see them very
localist very strong a sense of a very
strong fear of far-removed power and
they don't want no part of this
convention and they stay out of the
Union until 1798 Sal OTT of pressure
from the outside and and and the threat
by Providence the city which is
dominated by merchants to actually leave
the state and join the Union on its own
that that finally forces Rhode Island to
ratify the Constitution belatedly if you
lived in a country right now that had a
similar situation around the world that
the colonies had to Great Britain and I
don't know if there is one that you can
think of and based on what happened in
this country what would have to happen
well what are the key things that would
have to happen
in order to arrive at a constitution and
set up a new government and have a
democracy and all that kind of thing
well I think you have to have an
experienced political elite and this is
the one thing that that somehow is used
to governing itself it isn't enough to
just copy our Constitution and people
have have tried that I remember a few
years ago I was in Brazil and in 1987
and they were drawing up a new
constitution for themselves one of many
they've done and I was on a television
program and a radio program and they and
they asked me well what's the secret to
your to your Constitution which is
lasted for 200 years and what advice do
you have for us and I said keep it short
well of course that that was a mistake
because they already had it was 350
articles long and it was page after page
the beauty of our constitution was that
it's short but it can't be transformed
you can't just take our Constitution and
impose it on another culture it won't
work what really was the secret to our
success I think was that we had this
very very highly educated relatively
speaking for the 18th century highly
educated population with a good deal of
experience in what we might call
representative or democratic politics
and that is what was crucial and the
fact that they were English that is the
English law common law a sense of
English rights all of those things were
very very important that cannot be
simply transposed to another culture at
another time how much of the
Constitution was written by white men
because they owned property and they
wanted to keep it and get more well that
was Charles beards charge I think
Charles beard Charles beard was a story
in a wrote a book called the economic
interpretation of the Constitution
probably the most notorious book in all
of American history 1913 he got fired
from Columbia for writing it but that
was his charge and I don't think that
that's the way to look at these men
why'd he get fired well because he was
such a outrageous book that he had
written you see I don't know what
happened to tenure back then but but
that that thought your is a free country
there's some things you can't say back
then you couldn't couldn't denigrate the
founders that's the way he did it was
the progressive view of the revolution
and the founders that they were there
was this kind of selfish economic basis
to their to their actions beard actually
was what transcended that he wasn't
quite as bad as I'm applying here but
there were a lot of people read him that
way but anyway that's always easy to say
but but I think their their motivations
are much more complicate
they certainly were concerned about the
union they were concerned about this
country that they had invested their
lives that risked their lives for and
they wanted it to succeed
now Truitt Madison was concerned about
what what he called demagoguery
democratic politics that was violating
the rights of property and in his state
of Virginia and elsewhere but I think
his interests are go beyond just his own
concern for his property I think he
really was concerned for this thing
called the United States as a vision as
a dream this republican experiment was
that stake what would they have said
what would the founders have said if
confronted today with the question of
what right did you have you take this
land away from the Indians they would
have said I think and they did say that
first of all the Indians weren't using
it properly that is to say they weren't
farming it they felt that simply to have
this large these large expanses of land
and so hunt on them was was was a waste
that farming should be if the Indians
would convert to farmers they could have
the land they could have land that they
were willing to give them land but they
certainly weren't entitled to tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of acres
that that couldn't be tilled and that
was the logic of of the case and then
they resorted to to war or treaties they
bought it from the Indians they would
make a treaty with the Indians course
the Indians schist the fully understood
what what was involved in these treaties
they didn't think they necessarily were
giving up land in some cases the agents
who would sign the treaties weren't
necessarily speaking for for for other
Indians so you have a real problem of
but mainly it's a demographic tragedy
that is to say the Indians are declining
in population these these colonists are
growing in population and there was just
an inevitable tragedy built into the
situation then there's no doubt that
there was all kinds of shenanigans at
the local level
however worthy the ideals of people like
Washington
or Henry Knox who was a secretary of war
how much they wanted to treat the
Indians fairly at the local level there
was simply a feeling the only good
Indian is a dead Indian there's too much
of that thinking but given the
population developments demographic
growth it's hard to see any alternative
but we still owe the Indian something
well we're proving that by giving them
all kinds of gambling rights that I'm
sure lots of people puzzled by this that
I know in my in the state of Connecticut
nearby where I live there are huge
gambling casinos that have risen up
which are unique to the state that is
and and these come from the the I think
the breaking of treaties that that we
were involved in in in the early time
early part of our history and and this
is a kind of belated compensation not
necessarily the best way to why wouldn't
they have the right to gamble as much as
the white man whatever right to gamble
well they many cases you can't white men
today can't set up a gambling in New
London Connecticut you can't just set up
a gambling casino it's only at the
Foxwood in this little piece of
sovereignty that the the Pequod Indians
have as a result of being mistreated
back in the 1790 so it's a peculiar kind
of compensation that we're making and
it's very uneven because there are
Indians in North Dakota who don't have
the opportunity to set up again we go
back to the again the period of 1760
through the Revolutionary War where was
the black person in this country
well most blacks were held as slaves and
most slaves there were about a half a
million most slaves were held by
southern planters but everyone I think
every white calling us in one way
directly or indirectly benefited from
this institution of slavery
how many black slaves were there in the
north numbers well probably less than a
hundred thousand I haven't got Brad off
the top of my head that the actual
numbers but they were it was substantial
for example in New York
14% of the population of New York was
enslaved I think 7 percent in my own
state of Rhode Island less fewer slaves
in in the New England states and and in
the other northern states but it was
still a national institution prior to
the revolution so it but in the North it
succumbed to precious economic and it
was capable pressures that that
eliminated it everywhere in the north by
1804 at least on the record books now
slaves continued to exist in New York
because they were grandfathered in there
so let me ask you was that a moral
question for those who didn't have her
own slaves were they the ones that said
you can't have him I mean was it with
very many people who stand up and say
I've got slaves but they were some there
were many who were slaveholders who in
fact none of the revolutionary leaders
ever condone slavery even though they
were slaveholders like Patrick Henry he
said I cannot justify the institution I
know it violates everything this
revolution is about but I can't do
without them and Jefferson too he was a
slave holder through his whole life but
never justified it he always knew that
it was something wrong with it
so none of the major leaders ever
condoned it but of course there were
many who did not have slaves who were
critics but there were many critics
among the slaveholders themselves
actually there were more anti slave
societies in the south in the after
mediate aftermath of the revolution than
in the north so the south I think
actually they everyone thought the
institution would die it was an illusion
but they thought it would die they
thought that the ending of the slave
trade which was predicted by this
building of the Constitution the 1808
they could Congress could act on the
slave trade and everyone assumed that
once the slave trade was was killed that
the institution would die away well they
were wrong is there an example of any
white man back in those days who had a
considerable number of slaves who said
they're all free oh yeah but leaders
yeah well a young man of Virginian come
to Jefferson I think it's 1814 any man's
name is Cole he says look mr. Jefferson
speak out we need you we younger
generation need you I'm freeing my
slaves I'm moving to Illinois you speak
out and we can really do something about
this institution Jefferson says no I'm
too old you young people do it it's one
of his weaker moments Jefferson but this
young man goes on to Illinois becomes an
m5 it becomes a anti-slave becomes an
abolitionist and later governor of
Illinois Virginian who did just what he
wanted other how many of those well
there are not so many obviously
Washington freed his slaves upon his
death but they weren't his were they oh
yeah they were his wise well is why he
is he had some and his wife had some but
but whatever his wives his property his
wife's property is his but she they
weren't but greed until she died right
her slaves could remain but still they
he is he is ending the institution as
far as his family is concerned and that
that's something that others did not do
Jefferson didn't do that well now what
about women during this bridge
what role did they play and why were
they subservient at least they didn't
have all the voting rights and all I
don't know it's a patriarchal world it
always had been and what I think has to
be said is that that changes were for a
foot in the air not women didn't get
gave me the right to vote until much
later but I think there's a direct line
from the revolution to the Seneca Falls
of 1848 the first women's convention
there's the first essays appearing in
the newspapers
claiming the Equality of women coming
out of the Revolution but but women's
live lot by today's standards are just
very dependent they are considered to be
as children in the household their
husbands control their property control
their lives they are regarded as little
more than children legally now of course
in actual fact lots of women have lots
of influence because of their
personalities and so on but still
legally they are like children when they
marry their
they marry their husbands if Thomas
Jefferson and Ben Franklin and James
Madison and George watch all these folks
were sitting around this room now today
based on what you know that they thought
back then and you told them that there
are 40 black members of the house 60
women or something on that number
there's and there are Indians who were
members of the house of that Senate and
all what would they really think about I
think they wouldn't be that surprised so
as many of them like someone like
Benjamin Rush for example really
believed that in the natural equality of
people that if once you could educate
people you there was no reason why
anyone can't be become a leader but I
wonder if though did they know then when
they were right in the Constitution that
was some agitation over the years what
has happened what happened well I don't
know if they couldn't they couldn't have
predicted everything of course but I
think they would be really quite pleased
to know that the United States had
become the a great nation I think that
was their dearest dream they would not
they could imagine the Civil War I think
they knew that that was a section there
was a possibility of a sectional problem
over slavery but I think they would have
they wouldn't be totally surprised by
what what's happened they would have
said oh my god this is this is a
magnificent nation that's been created
from these very very tiny beginnings I
think that's that so and I think that
the fact that they were black
representatives wouldn't and and women I
don't think would have been beyond their
imaginations no they they actually did
imagine a world where people could learn
I mean that's the Enlightenment that the
notion that that that we come into the
world as blank slates and can be
educated and and and and taught
different things what is happening the
Enlightenment to your own thinking in
the last 40 years of teaching Oh
as your own attitude about the
Constitution about the revolution swung
in any address I think my attitude
towards America is wrong I've spent some
time in England in fact I'm over there
in in London
for about five months again because I
like to go to England for periods of
time in order to appreciate America
better and I think that a lot of my
thinking about the United States has has
come from contrasting it with a with a
different country that's very similar
England which has a I think a much more
stratified society despite the changes
that have occurred in in England in the
last half-century we are very different
and and I want to appreciate that and I
can do that best if I if I live in
England for a while I think my attitude
towards America has changed of course by
studying history I a different
appreciation for the country III how's
it changed well I think of course when
you're young you just take your own
nationality for granted but I think I've
got a different appreciation of what it
means to be an American simply by
studying history good it's not good Abed
it's just that we are we one error we
objective er well we're very
self-obsessed which I think most nations
are but but living abroad you get you
obviously much more there's much more
criticism of the United States then then
then we can appreciate and that's why
September 11th was such a shock to us we
didn't realize that so many people
disliked this but I think I think the
the thing about the American Revolution
is that it created the ideology that
holds us together I think without that
revolution we would be I don't know like
Argentina a nation without any kind of
adhesive we have an intellectual and
ideological adhesive that makes us one
people insofar as anything can cuz we're
so diverse all are we better than France
you mean better I don't like to use the
word but I'm what I'm getting at is is
our system better well I think we're
more capable of absorbing diverse
immigrant people than the European
nations they're having a terrible
problem I can see this in England now
the French have the same problem you can
have an Algerian Arab who's been living
there for two generations and
most French don't believe that he's
French how come we don't hear more about
that here well I don't know because this
is our great achievement that we are a
nation based on based on beliefs to be
an American is to believe in something
not to be someone to be an Englishman is
still to be someone and they have a hard
time absorbing all these immigrants and
they've got a lot of them now and they
don't know how to deal with it we have
this this marvelous country which is
held together I think by ideology by a
set of beliefs that came out of the
revolution it keeps us together you
don't have to be someone you don't have
to have a certain ancestor you can learn
to be an American by coming to believe
in these things liberty equality
constitutionalism so on you don't have
to come from a certain race or ethnicity
that's not true of most of the world why
don't we hear much from people who came
from other countries that live here
became American citizens about the very
points that you're making well I don't
know maybe our educational system want
to be emphasizing this but I think most
Americans it can't be enough to be an
American to go to McDonald's I mean that
can't be the only adhesive that holds us
together it has to be something else and
it's our history and particularly the
revolution but our whole history is what
really holds us together and and if
people can can come to believe in in
that history or in the ideals that come
out of that history then that's enough
of an adhesive I think you mentioned
Great Britain where are you over there I
mean in London doing what Oh
actually just writing I'm writing a book
on Franklin just about completing it and
what about Ben Franklin well he's an
interesting American because he's the
least American in a way of the
revolutionary leaders he spent most of
his adult life the last years of life
the last 33 years of his life abroad and
really didn't know a lot of Americans
when he comes back here to die all of
his friends have either died away or
they become loyalists so he doesn't have
a lot of a lot of contacts here he's a
very interesting figure because of that
because he's he's so European
in his background and the least of
American although he's become the most
folksy of the revolutionary leaders and
that's my story I think and when's your
book gonna be finished oh well I'm
almost done but I don't know when it'll
be completed we're coming up to the
300th anniversary of Franklin's birth
the first founder to have 300 years he
was born in 1706 and so in 2006 we're
gonna have he's his anniversary so at
the end of a semester one of your
students comes up to you and says
professor would the following happened
to be over the last semester what's the
best thing they can say to you about
your teaching what's the best thing they
could say yeah when do you feel like
you've done yourself as a professor Oh
when if they say look you've given me a
better understanding of my own culture
if they can say that then you're that's
all the rewards you need is to have some
students say I understand what it is to
be an American better because I took
your course Wow how can you how can you
do better than that Brown University
professor Gordon s wood this is the book
it's a modern library chronicles book
it's called the American Revolution a
history it's available for 1995 thank
you very much for joining us thank you